[Music]
i want you to solve this hannah problem
bring her in
there's going to be consequences
this is the moment we've all been
waiting for
you're going out into the wide world
and you won't be coming back you're
soldiers you have to be ruthless
in this war
anything
[Music]
you're goes at a list of targets for
assassination all the names on the list
are young politically motivated
socially conscious
[Music]
did you know about any of this i was
given a kill list i didn't know how they
made it well now you know
who are you
you're trying to destroy an organization
that wants you dead i need to get you
out of here now
if we're successful you could have
whatever life you want
i wouldn't know what to do with it
i only know how to fight
they tell you so much about what you're
supposed to do
not one word about what happens after
hunter down just like we taught
[Music]
20 years i'd let one little girl live
that girl came back to haunt me
i'm fighting in my head all the time
and you help me understand why
let's walk out together
trust me
she's coming for you
[Music]
my
you